[Music]
all right congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez and other
democrats unveiling their
radical extreme green new deal today to
address what she calls catastrophic
climate change
the world's going to end in 12 years or
scary i'm calling her
anyway here to get the latest on whether
this is the right
decision based on the right science he's
a competitive enterprise
institute senior fellow christopher
horner weatherbell.com
chief meteorologist our friend joe
bastardi um
okay chris let's start with you you've
written a number of books on the subject
if we're gonna offer we're gonna demand
every business and house
in the country be rebuilt and we're
gonna offer free college
free housing free health care free
retirement
free free free everything's free um
and the reasoning is we're gonna the
earth's gonna end in 12 years so we'll
do this
at 10 years with only two years to
benefit from it that's going to cost
trillions and trillions and destroy
capitalism the energy health care
uh industries and so many others um good
idea
right because it's worked uh not in
those places president obama used to
tell us to look to
to see how it would work out uh when he
tried baby steps toward this
uh wrenching transformation of society
as al gore called it
um we used to be the only ones not doing
it now we're told well we'll be the
first
you'll see this this plan opens with the
the alarmist liturgy but then it
reels off page after page of what you
noted this this progressive boilerplate
about
guaranteed income and so on for those
unwilling to work uh there's no mention
of a climate impact there's no mention
of a change in temperature which is the
flag it sells in under but
there's no one who actually claims it
would impact the climate this is about
the the fundamental transformation uh
you'll see in the washington post
tomorrow a scathing editorial pointing
out that
you're you're you're trashing the the
the enterprise of the climate industry
here by going off
on your your massive project meanwhile
they claim it would
cure these social ills it would
exacerbate badly
well this is the true energy poverty
energy poverty and so on joe the 70s was
the nice new ice age is coming then
global warming
the earth has the temperature and it's
going to explode in in a number of years
that passed already um now we just say
climate change but it's really
predicated on what uh a battle against
capitalism
that the premise that that man on earth
uh is is pillaging the planet for profit
well first of all h.l menken who was a
democrat said it
correctly the urge to save humanity is
almost always a false face for the urge
to rule it
and i think that's what you're seeing
here today what gets me is and i wrote a
book on as you know sean
you're dragging the majesty of the
creation
weather climate all these things i've
loved since i was a kid
being dragged through the mud it's the
weaponization of weather the
weaponization of climate the idea that
the average person doesn't know what
happened in the 70s or the 30s or the
40s or the 50s
like people like me
what they do is they simply take
advantage of it and
you know i almost have to laugh at it
now because you would have to sell your
soul to that world to understand that
world
and that's exactly what's going on here
it's really not that much
look i understand the co2 feedback
argument but the oceans have 99.9
percent
of the heat capacity of the entire
system if the ocean cyclically warm
the air cyclically warms when the oceans
cool the air will cool the last thing i
gotta say this pretty simple
relationship
you know every storm you have studied
whether and chris you have studied this
people need to pay attention a little
bit to what you're saying thank you both